[Music]
to being really suddenly got a bit of
sacrifice
we have one common goal and that's to
win a championship for me
yes
in the 2008 NBA Draft Russell Westbrook
from UCLA
[Music]
and we were playing the great touch of
snow a year
this real good is we're good guard guard
the other team's best player and I
suggest this what I'll do I mean
whatever it takes for my team to win
that's what I'm here for
I'm a point guard you know I would chop
my best and go out and do what I can for
the team and try to help him any way I
can
right
that was a great very got on off the
toilet I think that their Nexus to no
clothes on the floor
I call my little brother for the ugly
and their great chemistry right there so
I want to go there you know and try to
help them out
we get attached to people you know cuz
you with these guys fighting with these
guys you build a pressure with them only
years
you know starting to come family there's
some news out there that you really
can't do nothing with you know they got
too much in their bag you kind of go to
buy with them at the all-star game begin
Los Angeles westward makes his Saul star
appearance having a monitor year Russell
was
cats tie puts it down
is just awe-inspiring when you see them
close especially live in it versus the
Thunder and the Duggan's came one
[Applause]
what's for Hope a look at a three
out of fear
Wow
[Applause]
every night I try leave on the floor
that's a major the game on the floor I'm
always happy with the result
that's the seven and off we go okay see
one
you'll be in the Western Conference
final Westbrook's though is strong to
the basket and
fleet has been made up look
here is Westbrook determined and does
[Music]
[Music]
what do you guys have to do to make it
the MBA class take one day at a time
I expect a lot out of myself put a lot
of pressure on myself to become a very
very great player welcome to the Western
Conference Finals a heavyweight matchup
narrowing up a couple of powerpack big
three
I think the bronze at the redemptive
stage he's been challenged by everybody
he started not listening to all the
critics Russell was one answering every
Big Shot from the heat
so I think he except now I'll do
whatever it takes I'm gonna play my way
right shape layout banks today there was
an ease and calm
Westbrook sidestep all in a play from
Russell Westbrook and it's a one-point
game the best basketball for the Bron
James I believe is ahead of them
[Music]
kind of scary isn't it we haven't seen
the best of LeBron Jameses LeBron James
captures that elusive title he's so
desperately coveted
that's a it's a bitter disappointment
they
the Thunder didn't want to give Hardin
the max James hard going from a title
contender at OKC to a rebuilding project
in Houston mom is tough which is how it
goes at some time and James is going to
make the best decision for him his
family
I think we have something special here a
group of guys has been together for a
while we understand each other I mean
it's definitely never too busy to
together work on your game and come back
and head write a play biggest step for
us is just get better each and every
year we've gotta say what happens
throughout the year
there's nobody like this guy so the big
news
Westbrook
really upset with beveling right now
it's devastating
it's truly heartbreaking we never want
to see it happen you're just talking
about a year out of your prime you're
not able to play basketball it was just
a basketball
look at the baby bear the main focus is
to win championship every year ask time
I try to do Westbrook's offering a face
fracture he underwent surgery today this
her holding his ankle
that's what
he says Russell has made history it's
been a it's been a treat for watching
flora got whomped for
towards a sustainable night
Westbrook promises Kevin out our
offerings and different things on our
team changes so he goes down a second
time
you start doing things
Michael Jordan or Oscar Robertson my job
is to go out there compete at a high
level I've been blessed to play this
game
[Music]
this year's
hey Award winner Russell Westbrook
one thing we know about this guy right
here he's gonna work hard but I don't
really need a nothin to drive me to be
who I want to be to be where I want to
be we know when the playoffs car run
turn around
[Music]
[Music]
the biggest name biggest fish still out
there in Kevin Durant Oklahoma City or
both the state of the two frontrunners
where he thought he had the best chance
to win going forward and he clearly
thinks too small to state Kevin Durant
decision to leave the Thunder God there
have fun man
with a board to a lot of fun breasts
what are your expectations when your
main focus is to win championship
nassima try to do lawyers versus thunder
the Kevin Durant I'm coming I'm coming
as his former star Siemens
this might be the greatest season I've
ever seen a player hell it's an average
of triple-double I think we just try to
get better man I think if you don't win
the championship you gotta be the best
things to do it the amount of energy to
go out and do that every single night is
amazing I mean I think it'll be blessed
with the talents to get it done to
bounce a lot of things you're doing and
that's not fair you see guys get triple
doubles all right Noah 13th one he
averaged 28 points a game
back to raw speed shot
joy a story
[Applause]
he's a hybrid like he has a motor so
it's tough to stop a guy like that as
you can see
I take too much pride time F
to compete and play hard every night I
was play man to see
great defensive possessions really get
the assist he will
[Applause]
in 2017
Most Valuable Player Award is Russell
Westbrook
[Applause]
I know that when you do so much with the
game we've got so much impact in the
game I expect a lot out of myself this
is his third season in the world and
just brothers out there averaging a
triple-double and we always talk about
well he's not there so he's not that let
me tell you what he is he's a winner and
he's a guy that recognizes some of the
things that he could be better at the
loss from Nipsey Hussle when you see
Russ honoring this man is because he led
by example
they know what that means
nobody those can do it I can do
basis naturally believed that if they
could I'm pretty sure they would tear
star players have to play like stars
[Music]
[Applause]
the brilliance of Damian Lillard on full
display
[Music]
[Applause]
if you want to determine my career and
what I've done over to three games you
go ahead
okay woohoo I am the person always look
at myself for how I can be better
the 11 years the longest-tenured
active player with the same team the
Thunder training their franchise player
the guy that has been 11 years in
Oklahoma City
I only care about one team and that's
Houston Rockets everybody else no
worries
it was James Harden's desire to reunite
with Russell Westbrook's early and
mutual desire they decided they wanted
to play together again he knew James
Harden talked right in the aftermath
hey this is Russell Westbrook at
Oklahoma City Thunder and through that
grill
I've been getting a lot of heat ladies
is coming out and just trying to play my
game that's all I'm doing you just think
about how much players around the league
have talked about what it is that buses
represented on a nightly basis
[Music]
now absolutely respect oh I have
when I watch and blood
I see a lot of resemblance his passion
for the game basketball
we've done
what better what are you talking about
now
leadership is one thing got up taking
pride in finding ways to make other guys
better that's my whole thing creating a
friendship and a brotherhood not about
supposed to take care of so please then
the guy that's been the face of OKC
eleven years of hidden when you think
about what he's done just how well he's
been as a player it's gonna be hard to
walk away from a player like Russell
Westbrook it's different you got
different guys but I'm happy man I'd be
rated said star count with the new guys
in embrace the moment